[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas esta emisión la
iniciamos en el parlamento europeo en
bruselas sima samar es una activista por
los derechos humanos y también
exministra para los asuntos de la mujer
en afganistán país del que los talibanes
retomaron el control en agosto de 2021
nuestra corresponsal en la capital belga
esther herrera ya luego con ella
justamente para conocer cuál es la
situación actual de las mujeres bajo el
mando de los extremistas
usted fue la primera mujer en ser
ministra de asuntos de la mujer durante
el gobierno de transición que hubo en
2002 con la caída de los talibanes cómo
se siente ahora cuando los talibanes han
vuelto al poder y las mujeres de nuevo
pierden sus derechos
lamento decir que el ministerio de
asuntos de la mujer se está convirtiendo
en el ministerio para la propagación de
la virtud y eso es una falta de respeto
a las mujeres de afganistán porque creo
que las mujeres como la unidad de la
población y las mujeres que dan a luz a
estas células no deben ser ignoradas por
completos sino piel completa en ningún
país logrará ningún desarrollo de paz o
seguridad o paz sostenible sin la
participación de las mujeres en prisión
no formen los talibanes intentan limpiar
su imagen intentando mostrar que no son
lo mismo que en el pasado que opino de
las conversaciones que están teniendo
lugar en noruega
creo que tienen que pasar a la acción
tienen que salir con lo que dicen tienen
que encontrar un camino legítimo en la
confianza de la gente y eso puede darse
a través de la participación del pueblo
en todos los sectores que en country the
people sports station every shakhtar
finalmente sigue habiendo esperanza para
afganistán el del sol beso
siempre hay esperanza yo como presidenta
de la comisión de derechos humanos creo
que los talibanes no le pueden quitar a
los fast carlos el conocimiento que les
dimos a través de la formación en
diferentes plataformas sobre sus
derechos y eso es una esperanza
en
el sistema de salud libanés se está
desplomando en medio de una profunda
crisis económica que ha generado el
éxodo de miles de enfermeras y médicos
se estima que alrededor del 40 por
ciento del personal médico entre 2000
enfermeras y 1000 doctores han huido del
país en busca de mejores oportunidades
de vida en europa y en los países del
golfo el siguiente es un reportaje de
etel bonet y diego ibarra
escenas como estas se han convertido en
lo cotidiano en la clínica el doctor
mario north ja
no se puede dar el lujo de perder
pacientes con la crisis económica la
super infracción y la crisis energética
este dentista ha perdido el 70 por
ciento de sus ingresos ahora trabaja
solo porque no pudo pagar al personal en
ningún otro lugar estamos trabajando de
manera tan precaria no podemos cobrar a
los pacientes en dólares pero compramos
todo el material clínico en dólares y
sólo podemos trabajar en las horas con
electricidad por lo que tenemos menos
pacientes donar
cada vez es más difícil encontrar
especialistas en el líbano muchos ganan
al mes menos de 150 dólares la doctora
lina trabaja en tres hospitales y tiene
una consulta privada pero aún así no es
suficiente para mantenerse no puedo
subir les las tarifas a los padres de
mis pacientes todo el mundo está aquí
atravesando fuertes dificultades
económicas mis hijos están estudiando en
la universidad y no querríamos irnos
pero el futuro es muy oscuro marilina
forman parte de ese grupo de médicos que
todavía resisten en el líbano mientras
un 40 por ciento de sus colegas ha
optado por emigrar a otros países el
éxodo de médicos ha obligado a los
hospitales privados a tener que reducir
o cerrar servicios lo que representa una
amenaza para la población en tiempos de
pandemia
el sector salud se ha visto muy afectado
con la migración de médicos por la
crisis económica estamos corriendo un
alto riesgo con el kobe 19 la capacidad
de los hospitales se ha reducido a un
40% y tenemos muchas dificultades
logísticas
el líbano ha sido reconocido durante
décadas como el hospital de medio
oriente por sus tecnologías y
especialistas pero ahora quedan pocos
médicos que apuestan por un futuro sin
profesionales que lo sustente el sistema
de salud libanés será una víctima más de
las múltiples crisis que afronta el país
y la escasez de personal médico se vive
también en algunas zonas deferencia se
estima que alrededor de 7 millones de
personas de ese país viven en lugares
con dificultades para el acceso a los
servicios de salud cuando los doctores
se jubilan en algunas regiones alejadas
es difícil reemplazarlos ya que quienes
podrían hacerlo prefieren vivir en zonas
no tan alejadas de las grandes ciudades
por temor a recibir menos ingresos karen
asia but fue a conocer uno de estos
llamados de ciertos médicos en el este
del país
esta ciudad en la montaña de los vosgos
no ha tenido un médico general desde
hace dos años
para atraer candidatos la ciudad ha
invertido de manera masiva convirtiendo
este hotel en un centro médico
este centro puede ser utilizado por tres
médicos
los trabajos de construcción costaron
350 mil euros la mitad lo paga el
municipio
estamos ansiosos por ver este lugar
funcionando hay gran necesidad de
servicios médicos en esta área muchos
están luchando sin un médico a su
alcance este paciente ha logrado
conseguir una cita con un fisioterapeuta
no puedo conducir en este momento así
que necesito pedirle a la gente que me
lleve a lugares si no hay un médico
cerca es muy molesto para todos
hay un médico a unos 7 kilómetros de
aquí pero está tan ocupado que no puede
aceptar nuevos pacientes la ciudad ha
intentado contratar profesionales de la
salud
desde el 2018 nos hemos gastado casi 11
mil euros en anuncios clasificados
ni siquiera eso ha dado resultados la
ciudad recurrió a una agencia de
contratación internacional pagando 30
mil euros para intentar encontrar un
médico extranjero que aceptara
instalarse en la ciudad antes la agencia
solía encontrar médicos exclusivamente
en europa del este
ahora se está centrando también en el
sur de europa principalmente grecia
los residentes aislados al menos tienen
su farmacia local que les proporciona
medicamentos
nos dan prescripciones médicas en
consultas eso es en cierto modo parte de
su trabajo
lo que es realmente útil es poder
obtener mis medicamentos de uso continuo
incluso cuando no obtuve una nueva
prescripción
hace tres años la farmacia instaló un
computador para que sus clientes
pudieran realizar vídeo consultas
me sugirieron que consiguiera este tipo
de consulta hasta que un médico pudiera
venir a la ciudad se suponía que me
visitaría cada tres meses pero nunca
hemos visto a nadie así que sigo
teniendo estas consultas por vídeo
cada tres meses y janet de 62 años tiene
una cita para controlar su problema de
diabetes 30 residentes utilizan estas
vídeo consultas con la esperanza de que
algún día un médico los examine en
persona la república democrática del
congo ha sido escenario de múltiples
enfrentamientos violentos a lo largo de
las últimas tres décadas miles de
jóvenes incluyendo muchos niños han sido
reclutados por grupos armados un
problema que naciones unidas ha
calificado como endémico cubo montgó
quien fue uno de esos niños soldados
durante la primera guerra del congo a
finales de los 90 logró escapar y se
convirtió en un campeón de boxeo ahora
dedica su tiempo a asesorar a niños en
goma comidas a ayudarlos a construir un
mejor futuro el siguiente es un
reportaje de ellos tenca bumba julio de
uva y clima moro
y bongó es una celebridad en el barrio
mapendo en goma todas las mañanas este
campeón de boxeo entrena gratis a
jóvenes de toda la ciudad un niño ex
soldado durante la primera guerra del
congo a fines de la década de 1990 luego
ganó campeonatos y viajó por todo el
mundo ahora está tratando de transmitir
valores a sus alumnos cuando miro hacia
atrás mi vida pasada me vuelve loco pero
ahora he encontrado estabilidad hoy
lucho por la paz cuando entreno a los
jóvenes nos animó a buscar nuevas
oportunidades para participar en
competiciones de ciencias la mayoría de
ellos ni siquiera se ven como muchos
niños huérfanos acaban viviendo en la
calle algunos son víctimas de
delincuentes y grupos armados que
intentan reclutar los para evitar que
sufren el mismo destino que un hongo ha
capacitado y asesorado a más de 400
jóvenes
mis padres murieron cuando yo era
pequeño y desde entonces vivo en la
calle la gente me respetaba cuando mis
padres vivían pero después de que
murieron la gente dejó de preocuparse el
boxeo ayuda mucho
ahora las personas que seguían a
amenazarme no se atreven a hacerlo y la
termino en goma después de huir de la
violencia en su ciudad natal sobrevive
con trabajos ocasionales pero gracias al
boxeo ahora sueña con un futuro mejor la
vida es dura y como todo el mundo trato
de salir adelante el levanto temprano
entreno todos los días antes del trabajo
realmente tengo que doblar mis esfuerzos
porque me gustaría competir en
campeonatos africanos y mundiales ese es
mi objetivo
chivo montgó también tiene grandes
ambiciones para sus clases de boxeo
mi objetivo es abrir una escuela de
boxeo donde los jóvenes también puedan
aprender un oficio
por ejemplo mecánico sería como un
garaje con un ring de boxeo
y hasta el próximo round que bombón con
sus alumnos no tienen miedo de luchar
contra retos más grandes
este 14 de febrero se celebró el día de
san valentín o una oportunidad perfecta
para regalar entre otras flores 650
millones de flores colombianas llegarán
este año a más de 100 países del mundo
un éxito en exportaciones que tiene sin
embargo varias caras una de ellas son
los reclamos sindicales por mejorar las
condiciones laborales de miles de
floricultores en todo el país el
siguiente es un reportaje de luís muñoz
el día del amor se siente en el ambiente
buenos dias paola elvira supervisa la
recolección de rosas en un cultivo en
nemocón a una hora de bogotá la capital
de colombia lleva 33 años en la empresa
toda su vida dedicada al negocio todo mi
tiempo y todo mi amor al trabajo lo he
dedicado a las flores
porque las flores también me transmiten
eso y ha podido llegar y lograr tener
mis cosas y mis objetivos y metas que he
podido lograr
colombia exporta en estos días 650
millones de tallos a más de 100 países
en 2021 el país registró mil 544
millones de dólares en exportaciones de
flores la cifra más alta de la historia
para ellos se organizan en el plan
pétalo carolina pantoja es su directora
reivindica el valor de la rosa para
colombia'
queremos exportar expedientes
respiradores para que los consumidores
finales puedan expresar sus sentimientos
y puedan disfrutar de las flores
colombianas vamos en facatativá a 45
kilómetros de bogotá está gladys
pertenece al sindicato nacional de
trabajadores del sistema agroalimentario
durante seis años trabajó en las flores
desde hace una década asesora y acompaña
a otras trabajadoras del sector gladys
se encuentra en la sede sindical con
marco antonio un compañero de luchas ex
trabajador de las flores tiene
familiares a los que no ve desde hace
más de un mes y de sis la explotación el
exceso de trabajo el maltrato son
tranquilamente 18 20 horas seguidas y
sobre todo en post cosechar cuando el
ritmo la gente no tiene no tiene ni
siquiera oportunidad de dormir estas
rosas colombianas pronto llegarán a eeuu
europa y japón los enamorados las han
buscado a lo largo de la historia son el
símbolo del amor pero en colombia sólo
el 50 por ciento de las exportaciones
tienen el certificado de buenas
prácticas
gracias por acompañarnos en una nueva
emisión de corresponsables nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom